ils sortent de la salle un peu
désorienté il est 7h30 et depuis 4h30 du
matin c'est qu'elle étudiants planchent
sur les épreuves du concours le plus
difficile pour beaucoup la gestion du
temps et l'heure matinale
je suis plutôt satisfaite dans le sens
où j'ai réussi à terminer
et puisqu'à la fin j'ai eu un peu de mal
à finir j'ai tant que juste même très
juste comme on a commencé à 4h30 du
matin donc gérer le temps et en même
temps la fatigue c'était un petit peu
assez au fait c'était compliqué et puis
vu qu'il y avait beaucoup d'informations
qui me venaient tous et le temps était
très limité puisque c'était une épreuve
en trois heures j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
à enfin oui à finir une voie qui permet
à ces jeunes de s'engager dans des
études de haut niveau tournée pour
beaucoup vers l'international mais qui
leur permettra aussi de se mettre au
service de leur pays
j'hésitais entre le droit et les
sciences politiques donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai choisi cette voie je sais pas
trop ce que je veux faire mais je sais
que je vais retourner en martinique
et pourtant la mise en place de ce
concours fut un véritable parcours du
combattant
et c'est grâce à la volonté d'un certain
nombre d'enseignants et à la demande des
élèves qu'il a pu se tenir ici faut
savoir que généralement pour les
concours d'entrée à sciences po il ya
des centres d'examens qui sont verts que
ce soit en première année où en deuxième
année
donc là à ce moment là il a fallu réagir
très vite pour contacter sciences po
lyon il y avait aussi sciences po aix et
de zipper qui n'avaient pas ouvert deux
centres d'examen martinique pour leur
demander d'ouvrir un centre d'examen
chez de façon à ce que nos étudiants
aient la possibilité de passer ce
concours alors dans l'urgence on a dû
tout sera organisée avec sciences po
lyon
la démocratisation de ce concours est de
plus en plus une réalité une opportunité
pour les élèves martinique est ce qu'il
faut que les familles sachent c'est que
on peut préparer sens policiers que
n'importe quel jeune peut réussir
sciences po moi j'ai des étudiants qui
arrivent à la faculté de droit et qui
ont des niveaux moyens qui sont pas
forcément qu'ils n'ont pas forcément
fait un parcours extraordinaire mais
justement mon travail c'est de leur
donner les moyens de leur réussite ça
demande beaucoup de travail ça me
demande beaucoup d'investissement
personnel mais tout le monde peut y
arriver pour peu qu'on est consacré
man une année entière de sa vie par
contre le concours de sciences po aix en
provence n'a pu se tenir ici les élèves
sont donc obligés de partir pour le
passé ce qui génère un coût non
négligeable
une cagnotte a été ouverte pour les
aider à faire face aux frais